how are you feeling now that the
election cycle
is over well you know it's weird because
to be honest
i i kind of miss getting texts from all
the political candidates
all the time you know yeah i know what
you mean it does
feel a little weird i used to get tons
of texts and i haven't gotten any today
i'm glad you brought that up conan
actually i didn't
because i'm launching a new service
introducing
andy's list just donate 25 to andy's
list
and i'll text you seven to eight times
per day
asking you for more money sometimes i'll
even mix it up and say my name is
felicia or christine baranski and here's
the best part
the more money you donate the more text
you get
asking for money all right but what
exactly am i donating to
is it a non-profit organization it's
similar to that
except this is a profit non-organization
plus if you sign up for a recurring
monthly donation
i'll also send you threatening emails
and if you donate over
one thousand dollars i'll call your home
during dinner hours
and personally blame you for the state
of the country
uh okay andy why would anyone want this
people must like it because they keep
donating to political candidates
and with andy's list at least you don't
have to be disappointed when your
candidate eventually loses
hey i just got a text from andy's list
consider it your christmas present conan
another one how do i opt out oh you can
opt out at any time
just text back the words opt out in all
caps
and then you'll take me off the list
nope
andy's list if you're gonna waste your
money why not waste it on this
thanks andy you've wasted everyone's
time